the Trump rallies are becoming
increasingly politically relevant as
they are now regularly meant to support
2022 candidates now I was the first to
tell you last week Trump got two wins uh
JD Vance in Ohio
um as well as what was the other one now
oh uh J.R Majewski in Michigan who I
interviewed I should remember him Trump
endorsed two people and they won but now
we have a new challenge which is Dr
Mehmet Oz who is running for the senate
in Pennsylvania Trump has endorsed him a
lot of Republicans don't like Oz and the
most notable thing the most notable
thing about Trump's rally in support of
Dr Oz over the weekend was not only that
the crowd sometimes booed Dr Oz but that
Trump seemed visibly disoriented and his
speech was extremely confused now we've
gotten used to the glitches from Trump
like you might remember when Trump got
his own name wrong at a rally then he
went down Donald Trump here Donald Trump
when Trump got Obama's name wrong at a
rally
when when Trump got the name of Mexico
wrong at a rally Mexico when Trump got
Mitt Romney's name wrong at a rally a
rhino named Mitt Romney when Trump got
the name of someone he endorsed wrong at
a rally we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel when Trump got the name of his
own social media platform wrong at a
rally truth Central okay so but here
Trump actually seemed confused about
ideas for example in this first clip
Trump says Pennsylvania is where our
founding fathers declared American
Energy Independence what what
Pennsylvania is the Commonwealth where
our founding fathers
declared American Energy Independence
think of that you were the first ones
many many many years ago I don't know
what he's talking about maybe he just
means that Philadelphia is where
Independence was declared but energy
Independence is not making a lot of
sense visibly disoriented seemed almost
punch drunk then at another moment Trump
says that if Dr Oz wins his wife will be
the first lady of Pennsylvania but Oz Oz
is running for Senate not for governor I
could have chaos I could have had a
great out
I could have had and by the way your
wife is so incredible you're going to
get a great first lady in the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania you're
going to get that first lady I know her
well she's incredible and and does she
love her family her husband and her
family yeah so anyway Oz is running for
Senate not I guess if it was the
governorship you might say the first
lady of Pennsylvania but all very
strange at another Point Trump
seeming to be kind of impressed in some
way that maybe Oz's TV show gets him
girls I mean this is just strange stuff
I've known him a long time his show is
great he's in that
he's on that screen he's in the bedrooms
of all those women telling them good and
bad
and they love him he came into a place
where we had a lot of women sitting
there waiting for something unrelated
they started going crazy is that Dr Oz
that's Dr Ross yeah so Trump seemingly
jealous I guess of uh the effect that
Oz's show has on women now in all
seriousness the entire rally was
supposed to be for Oz and there was
actually quite a bit of booing whenever
his name would come up it doesn't seem
the Trump crowd is necessarily sold on
Oz my friend Dr Mehmet Oz he's a great
man
and even a bunch of people interviewed
before the rallies said that I am not
sold on Oz here uh Trump did an
impression of a rocket ship at one point
we endorsed JD and he was like a rocket
ship he went
boiling uh and then at another point he
came very close to calling Mitch
McConnell a POS which I I love quite
frankly I think the more that these
people can fight amongst themselves the
better
tree according to them but no he's an
old broken down
Crow I want to be nice I don't want to
call oh I wanted to have I had that word
right that I just want that I couldn't
do
I'd go home and the first lady would say
why didn't you use that foul language
darling I love you so much but why did
you use it
he said oh broken down piece of crow
[Applause]
yeah a piece of crow
um and then just some surreal
kafka-esque moments and at one point a
speaker brought up by Trump referred to
him as Donald
Donald Trump
[Applause]
really quite a cast of characters
um when Mehmet Oz spoke it was pouring
he was soaking wet and he talked about
keeping the borders clean which I don't
even know what that means face and we'll
fight back are you on the fight China
fight for our kids in our schools
are you gonna fight back to keep our
borders clean
you're gonna fight back them yeah you
got to keep those borders clean maybe
with like an injection almost of bleach
or something like that and then maybe
the most surreal moment Dinesh D'Souza
spoke he has like a new I can't even
call it a documentary because it's all
Bs he has a new
he has a new uh uh series of stitched
together Audio Visual
bits I guess is what we can call it and
he has developed the term ballot
trafficking it's not a term I've heard
before he may be using the same random
word generator that Trump uses uh but
here he is listen to this and
to give someone else your ballot and
have them drop it off usually the
conditions of that are kind of specified
they're clear in Georgia for example you
can give your ballot to a family member
or if you are in a confined facility you
can give it to a caregiver and as you
can see just an incredibly riveting
speaker the people on stage right behind
Dinesh uh talking amongst themselves
many of them not even facing Dinesh very
very strange stuff and lastly it's not a
trump rally until Trump literally leaves
you stranded in the mud here is video of
with YMCA playing listen to this
[Music]
leaving in the mud trying to get around
barriers it's completely flooded Trump
got the hell out of there and it is a
classic at these rallies horrible
conditions people getting stuck
sometimes for hours and just really a
display of the absolute worst worst
worst of American culture and politics
so the question will be
does Oz win the primary with Trump's
endorsement because this one doesn't
seem to be going quite as well as some
of the others we'll have these clips on
our Instagram make sure you're following
us there at davidpakman show
one of our sponsors today is Helix sleep
and it's a sponsor I'm thrilled about
because I sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about Helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do I need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your back
pain issues you might have and they will
pair you with a mattress that will be
perfect for you I took the Sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what I needed I often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and I've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all Helix mattresses come
with a 10-year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
I think you will all of my viewers will
get up to 200 off your order and you'll
get two super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video